ich brauche ich wieder arbeiten alle
also was hältst du von mir glaubt ja wie
viel
euro im monat
[Musik]
beim sogenannten cfd-trading verlieren
circa 73 prozent aller kleinanleger geld
ich bin im rahmen des experiments
bereits den gesamten einsatz zu
verlieren und würde außerhalb einer
solchen produktion niemals derart
risikoreiche geschäfte eingehen denn
noch verkäuflich das thema auf keinen
fall und möchte es relativ sachlich
behandeln
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist okay die woche beginnt das ist um es
zu sagen eines videos auf die ich am
allermeisten gespannt bin einerseits
weil ich weiß dass das risiko krasses
und ich halte hier natürlich echtes geld
bringen kann
andererseits auch weil ich das thema
absolut spannend findet und ich absolut
gar keinen plan
wirklich ich habe niemand leben
irgendwie eine aktie angefasst
persönlich deswegen bin ich als
allererstes mal damit nicht ausreichend
über dieses thema zu informieren und wir
alles was ich kann
wenn ich das auch im internet und dort
findet man auch einiges an literatur
häufig seriös diese sucht kann ähnlich
einer spielsucht werden und leuten in
den totalen häufig unseriös
also ich kann nur jedem empfehlen das zu
versuchen es ist immer leicht
theoretisch kann man mit cfd trading
wirklich schnell reich werden aber viel
wahrscheinlicher ist es laut statistik
dass man schnell arm wird die spreu der
trading coaches trennt sich meistens
aber relativ leicht vom weizen
denn immer wenn man dinge liest wie
investmentbanken hassen diesen trick
absolut narrensicher oder schlag schnell
zu bevor großbanken es verbieten dann
ist es wahrscheinlich bauernfängerei es
gibt aber wie gesagt auch viele seriöse
figuren in der szene die auf risiken
aufmerksam machen und nicht schnellen
reichtum versprechen ich eröffnete jetzt
ein konto bei einem broker da das
premium modell schon eine mindestanzahl
von 20.000 euro erfordert werde ich mich
mal getrost für das standard modell
entscheiden
wir werden direkt ziemlich private daten
das beschäftigungsverhältnis
selbstständig beruf influenza
jahreseinkommen da kann sie ja noch
drastisch reduzieren wenn ich hier mein
ganzes geld verzockt gesamtwert ihrer
ersparnisse ja ja das da geht es mir
aber nie wie schön wie groß ist ihre
erfahrung im handel von cfds also was
sind cfds cfds sind differenz verträge
das heißt man kauft sich zum beispiel
nicht wirkliche aktien oder gold sondern
handel mit wertpapieren die zum beispiel
den kurs einer bestimmten aktie abbilden
angenommen ich würde gerne mit apple
aktien handeln wollen müsste ich mir
also keine ganze aktion für aktuell 230
euro kaufen um mit den wertschwankungen
spekulieren zu können sondern ich könnte
mir wertpapiere im wert von zehn euro
kaufen die den apple kurs widerspiegeln
wenn die echte apple aktie und zehn
prozent fällt verliert also auch mein
investment in denselben prozentualen
wert üblicherweise trader man übrigens
mit einem sogenannten hebel sehr grob
gesagt werden mit einem hebel von 1 10
zum beispiel alle gewinne verzehnfacht
die verluste aber auch das ist natürlich
besonders riskant wie würden sie die
hebelwirkung von fx oder bin ich in der
schule oder was
die antworten die sie während der
illustren abgegeben das nur schließen
dass sie nur begrenzte kenntnisse hallo
sagen jetzt ja nur begrenzte kenntnis
und deswegen wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll
erst mal eine trading demo zu öffnen ja
wir haben wirklich ein volk wedding demo
testen jetzt nicht gleich direkt mit
geld los treten lassen
er ist sie schon herzlich aus nase und
krieg das schon ein bisschen schiss kann
man sich dann so eine sache an wagt also
wie ich jetzt zumindest und jetzt
komische geräusche
ich verstehe es nicht ich fühle mich wie
im online casino
ich war noch niemand was ich noch
nächstes experiment was sind das für
geräusche ist es ist wirklich wie im
online casino okay jetzt wird zum ersten
mal ernst ich habe noch nicht wirklich
viel ahnung ich weiß was ich hier gerade
jetzt euro und dollar handelt weiß dass
ich hier sachen kaufen und verkaufen
kann grob übersetzt heißt das links
wette ich quasi darauf dass die kurse
fallen und rechts bei bei werde ich
darauf dass ich unsere starken so viel
habe ich mitgekriegt ich weitet diesem
graf ab und wenn ja nach oben steigt
zähle ich und werde dadurch auf fallende
kurse
und wenn er danach wieder wundert geht
dann löse ich das auch keine ahnung ein
bisschen geduld ich fühle mich gerade
wie so [ __ ] der auf der jagd ist und
auch den richtigen moment gewartet
okay das ist oben geschnellt deswegen
habe ich jetzt drauf gewettet dass ich
danach wieder sinken
jetzt sehe ich hier rechts unten mein
aktueller gewinnen und jetzt bisher habe
ich grade verloren und jetzt wenn er
weiter runter sinkt dann wandelt sich
irgendeinen gewinnung und wenn ich jetzt
verkaufe habe ich 45 cents gewinn
gemacht
das guthaben 7000 euro alles natürlich
virtuelles geld und dass man zu testen
das mache ich richtig nervös das macht
mich richtig natürlich geht auch noch
gut verkauft und ein euro sitzen gewinne
macht ich weiß nicht so richtig was du
mir halten soll
wo ich bin jetzt jetzt bin ich hier fünf
euro im minus gewesen es geht recht
rasant
ich weiß noch gar nicht welchen
jeglicher drin habe ich bin jetzt schon
zehn euro im minus
nicht in 20 euro - ich weiß zwar dass es
nur ein demokonto ist aber trotzdem ist
das erlebnis echt ziemlich real
unwissend trading ohne irgendwelche
sicherheitsmechanismen noch ein paar
stunden weiter wozu das führt selbst ja
also es sind jetzt eben gar nicht mal so
gut aus mit den positionen mit denen ich
gerade drin wenn wenn ich gerade 1200
euro im verlust ich habe keinen plan ob
es jetzt sinn macht drin zu bleiben oder
ob sie mal rauszugehen
ich muss einfach mehr lernen muss mich
auf jeden fall mehr mit
ganzen handwerk auseinandersetzen und
mit den ganzen werkzeugen die hier zur
verfügung habe fazit für den ersten tag
sinn also 3640 das heißt ich habe schon
1460 euro verzockt abgesehen das ultra
risikoreich ist liegt auch daran dass
ich mich ja blöd angestellt hat habe
eine phase lang 18 mal hintereinander
nie wieder gemacht halt immer so
zwischen 20 cent aber hat auch mal acht
euro und halt recht stabil
hintereinander
aber dann plötzlich minus zwei und minus
zwei und minus 200 ja morgen wo ich mich
ganz klar zurück ich würde sagen ich
mache mir schon noch ein bisschen schlau
arbeitet ist es glaube ich gehe jetzt
darum aber auch ein kurzfristiger euro
gehen nach oben mal nach unten aktien
kurz beschrieben objekt weiter wir
ernähren uns - drei euro -4 wieder wobei
ich hatte vor einer halben stunde
eigentlich telefonat was ich jetzt
komplett verpennt hat sich einfach so
tief eingesetzt war und ich könnte jetzt
auch einfach gar nicht zurückrufen weil
halt jeder zeit sein könnte dass ich
halt aktiv sein muss magath ich habe
jetzt eine halbe stunde zugeguckt bis
der auftrag endlich für mich positiven
ist und jetzt endlich gerade verkauft
heute habe ich sogar 200 euro profit
gemacht natürlich durch glück aber auch
weil ich meine strategie geändert habe
und nicht mehr ganz so riskant gehandelt
habe aber bisher war das immer das
virtuelle geld vom demo konto also
möchte ich jetzt auf ein echtes geld zu
wechseln um echte gewinne aber auch
echte verluste machen zu können
unglücklicherweise hat mich jedoch der
brücke aufgrund meines jährigen
wissensstandes vorerst dazu verdonnert
weiterhin auf dem demo konto zu bleiben
und obwohl ich direkt nach der anmeldung
noch die möglichkeit dazu hatte diesen
vorschlag zu ignorieren habe ich sie
jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr und
telefoniere mit dem kunden support
dieser empfiehlt mir einfach mit einer
anderen e mail ein neues konto anzulegen
doch das geht auch nicht da sich der
blocker bereits meine handynummer meine
adresse und meinen namen gespeichert hat
prinzipiell finde ich diesen mechanismus
natürlich ziemlich gut da er anfänger
davon abhalten sollen diese verluste zu
machen der prozess zieht sich leider
etwas hin weswegen ich auch am dritten
tag noch mit dem demo konto und das ist
vielleicht besser so
und dann aufgrund eines gravierenden
verlustes am anfang verliere ich heute
knapp 400 virtuelle euro und das obwohl
ich am rest des tages ist relativ
souverän getötet habe ich schreibe noch
mal eine e mail an den kunden support
bezüglich des echtgeld kontos informiere
mich weiterhin über das trading und
mögliche strategien und werde von den
beiden hier zum spielen aufgefordert an
tag 4 warte ich immer noch auf die
freischaltung und mache mit insgesamt 44
trades immerhin 56 euro profit bin aber
natürlich immer noch 1500 virtuelle euro
im minus und am morgen von meinem
letzten trading wochentag ist es endlich
soweit nachdem ich meinen ausweis und
meine internet rechnung als bestätigung
meiner identität abgeschickt habe kann
ich schon mit echtem geld handeln
ok jetzt wird endgültig ganz 1000 euro
und jetzt diesen knopf clique kleineres
weg vielen dank ihr auftrag wurde
erfolgreich übermittelt ihr kontostand
1000 euro let's go das wird jetzt viel
von der demo auf live umgestellt okay
lass mal klein anfangen
ich mache mir den dollar mal ganz groß
ich tippe darauf dass der weiter
informiert das ist ein ganz anderes
gefühl einfach 1000 euro drin hat nicht
nur zu spiegeln habe ich werde jetzt
viel kleinere volumen handeln einfach
damit ich nicht pleite geht weiter jetzt
ist der ja hoch kommt und dann wenn er
ein bisschen oben es setze ich auf
fallende kurse
und zwar genau jetzt sogar die kurse
steigen die kurse steigen
ok - 19 sonst kann ich verkraften ok oh
ja ich bin 15 + ich brauche nie wieder
arbeiten alle die es geht manchmal geht
sie hat jetzt der ultimative fällt wenn
mein erster trailer einfach direkt in
die hose geht - 30 also 54 santino ich
glaube kaum
13 prozent aller okay ich habe 1000 euro
eingezahlt hat das 1000 euro 13 ich habe
ja gekocht und und verkaufen wieder hier
sind sie weiß dass ihr das bis nach oben
gehen und dann sagte ich habe trotzdem
ist sie wieder nach unten stehender
unten fällt das heißt man selbst die
leiseste anzeichen dass man macht nach
unten zu fallen werde ich wieder auf
fallende kurse setzen
als diese zweifel immer so dieses mal
kaufen so nicht verkaufen sollen dass
das schlimmste verkauft er die jetzt ist
es auch so was in die höhe geschossen
nein ich hab zwar oder richtung mich
aber nicht gesetzt ich habe auch so
sehen es nicht ich hab mich einfach
verlegt ich habe mit einem klick meinen
ganzen profit von eben jetzt verraten
ich habe das gefühl etwas falsch zu
machen wenn man einfach genau das
gegenteil von dem machen würde was ich
mache wenn man richtig rockig haben euro
verloren in euro ging so schnell
und so bleiben von 1998 das problem ist
ich habe immer nur so ein mega keine
gewinne aber bei den verlust und dass
ich mich viel zu weit ins minus 3 mich
ist heute glaube ich mal mehr mit
stoploss arbeiten also ich setze darauf
dass ist jetzt langsam wieder
also mache ich nichts hält und ihm ein
stop-loss bei etwas über diesem maximum
von rollen und jetzt wird er automatisch
quasi die gekündigt wenn der zu fuß -
geht und er geht gut runter ok ich
könnte jetzt auflösen und da hätte ich
die 60 cent aber natürlich nicht und
jetzt gehen nach oben und jetzt habe ich
bin - ich werde einfach mal ein bisschen
größere summen reinlegen ich frage mich
langsam ob es dann nicht mehr sinn
machen würde einfach in münster
geschlossen weil ich einfach nie richtig
liegt ich glaub ich glaube ist ein
bisschen langfristiger drin
diesmal und dass wir die nerven
aufreibend einfach was einsetzen ich
hier den weiteren trend beobachten und
dann aber auf fallende kurse jetzt mal
reinsetzen und dann wird es einfach mal
angucken und dann einfach mal wirklich
jetzt eine große bewegung abwarten und
schauen ob ich damit klarkommen mit dem
straße ich würde am liebsten einfach
auflösung den profit mitnehmen ich kann
gar nicht gut an
aber es scheint sich zu lohnen sie sind
bei zwei euro gewinn drei euro drei euro
fünfzig und das nehme ich mit vertrauen
sie mitgenommen
wir sind nur noch einen euro insgesamt
im minus steht aber weiter nach unten
gehen jetzt nicht dass ich eine ahnung
von dem was heute aber dass jemand heute
ich das noch umgehen wird h
runde sg nach unten let's go gegen ein
gutes stück nach unten ellbogen wieder
verkaufen wieder ein euro 80 oder 90
cent im plus das sieht in dem was wir
bisher gesehen hat beschränkt alles aber
das hätte ich gar keinen planung würde
ich einfach aus meinem bauchgefühl
heraus entscheiden und jana klar
einerseits habe ich noch immer keinen
plan und ich denke auch dass eine woche
dazu nicht wirklich ausreichend plan zu
haben sofern es einen funktionierenden
plan gibt aber zum anderen habe ich
tatsächlich auch wenn ich es nicht so
oft erklärt habe viel mit irgendwelchen
trendlinien widerständen gearbeitet und
verschiedene strategien versucht mit
denen ich persönlich aber auch nicht
mehr erfolg hatte als einfach aus dem
bauch heraus zu entscheiden
zu beginn habe ich nur kleine verluste
gemacht und manchmal sogar klitzekleine
profite wodurch ich mit dem höhepunkt
bei 1004 euro angelangt bin im laufe der
zeit habe ich immer größere summen
eingesetzt und mein guthaben von 1.000
euro ist rapide nach unten geschnellt
bis sich am ende bei 126 euro verlust
vorerst die bremse gezogen hat mir hat
diese woche noch nicht gereicht um ihr
endgültig eine meinung zu bilden zudem
habe ich natürlich auch noch immerhin
870 euro auf dem konto was sich
einsetzen kann
deswegen werde ich das ganze noch auf
dem monat ausstrecken mich noch mehr
informieren und dann mit hoffentlich
weniger risiko und mit mehr strategie
und mit mechanismen verluste zu
vermeiden da reinzugehen an der woche
war das nicht genug kam aber für mich
persönlich herausgestellt obwohl es
viele menschen gibt die davon süchtig
sind dass ich persönlich davon gar keine
suchtgefahr hat einfach dadurch dass ich
davon nicht konstant erfolgserlebnisse
krieg und nicht so hundertprozentig was
ich beeinflussen könnte ob es jetzt
klappt oder nicht habe ich persönlich
als überhaupt nicht ist verlangen dem
ganzen auf kampf noch mehr geld in den
rachen zu machen ich habe für dieses
experiment mehrere hör bücher
verschlungen um möglichst viel wissen
aufzusaugen es gibt eine app die
tausende bücher auf das wichtigste
zusammenfasst und das ganze blabla
herausstreicht wodurch man alle
essentiellen informationen in nur 15
minuten lesen oder sogar hören kann
anstatt dafür mehrere stunden zu
brauchen diese app heißt blinkt ist und
ist das sponsor des heutigen video link
ist peter ratgeber zeitlose klassiker
und bestseller aus produktivität
psychologie wissenschaft
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und vielem
mehr
und das auf deutsch und auf englisch am
besten gefällt mir dass man bücher in
doppelter geschwindigkeit werden kann
und ich somit alle wichtigen
informationen aus dem buch souverän
investieren wenn man zum aktienhandel
geht in nur acht minuten statt acht
stunden aufsaugen konnte somit kann man
auch perfekt herausfinden welche bücher
man später auch mal ganz lesen möchte
und jeden monat kommt ca 40 0
in 25 verschiedenen kategorien hinzu auf
link fsd.de / pommery könnt ihr sieben
tage lang kostenlos zu viele bücher
verschlingen wie ihr möchtet und das
noch bevor irgend ein abo abschließen
meine zuschauer erhalten exklusiv 20
prozent rabatt auf das jahres-abo
blickes premium ganz oben in der video
beschreibung einfach auf brink ist punkt
de / connery klicken und auf geld wenn
er nicht auf dieser reise begleiten
möchten und meinen versuch das geld
wieder zurückzuholen nichts verpassen
möchte jetzt dann abonniert gerne diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst mal
wieder ganz gut
[Musik]